hey man it's me kevin smith uh clips i'm
gonna show you some clips from my movies
this one right now
is uh the rain scene from chasing amy
man when uh ben affleck's character
holden mcneil
declares his love for joey adams
character alyssa jones uh
this is the scene if you look real
closely [ __ ]
you know when he's walking back to the
car you'll see the entire [ __ ] crew
reflected in the window i've been
hearing that [ __ ] for 24 [ __ ] years
man i'm like
that that's what you're picking up what
about cop out pick on all of that don't
pick on the one chasing amy reflection
scene
so yeah look closely you'll see the crew
reflected uh as
ben walks back to his truck and stuff in
the rain we got real lucky
uh with the rain uh rat face who was our
production designer robert holtzman
um he knew a guy named john berzicelli
who uh
worked in um a down but in
cherry hill area um that uh
worked for the fire department so he had
access to a fire truck
and had the rain towers so he made it
rain
for us like in that scene we were able
to that rain
wasn't real it was movie rain and [ __ ]
but our budget was 250 grand
so having fake movie rain was like such
a luxury and stuff
so uh check it out man there's wonderful
performances
heartfelt stuff and uh
a moment that you know honestly got joey
nominated for a golden globe that year
so enjoy
[Applause]
why are we stopping because i can't take
this
can't take what i love you
you love me i love you
and not not in a friendly way although i
think we're great friends
and not in a misplaced affection puppy
dog way
although i'm sure that's what you'll
call it i love you
very very simple
very truly you are the the epitome of
everything i have ever looked for in
another human being
and i know that you think of me as just
a friend and crossing that line is is
the furthest thing from an option you
would ever consider but
i had to say i just i can't take this
anymore
i can't stand next to you without
wanting to hold you
i can't i can't look into your eyes
without feeling that that longing you
only
read about in trashy romance novels i
can't talk to you without wanting to
express my love for everything you are
and i know this will probably
queer our friendship no pun intended
but i had to say it
so i've never felt this way before
and i don't care i like who i am because
of it
and if bring this to light means we
can't hang out anymore then
that hurts me but god i just i couldn't
allow another day to go by without just
getting it out there
regardless of the outcome which
by the look on your face is to be the
inevitable
shoot down and you know
i'll accept that
but i know i know that some part of you
is hesitating for a moment
and if there's a moment of hesitation
and that means you feel something too
and all i ask please is that you just
you just not dismiss that
and try to dwell in it for just 10
seconds
alyssa
there isn't another soul on this [ __ ]
planet
who has ever made me half the person i
am when i'm with you
and i would risk this friendship for the
chance to take it to the next plateau
because it is there between you and me
you can't deny that
even if you know
even if we never talk again after
tonight
please know that i am forever changed
because of who you are and what you've
meant to me
which well i do appreciate it
i'd never need a painting of bird
spotted a diner to remind me
this isn't something i said
[ __ ]
what are you doing get back in the car
and get out of here what you're gonna
hitch to new york
why aren't you at least gonna comment
here's my comment [ __ ] you
what that was so unfair you know how
unfair that was but it's unfair that i'm
in love with you now it's unfortunate
that you're in love with me
it's unfair you felt the [ __ ] knee
down burning your soul about it
do you remember for one [ __ ] second
who i am
so i mean you know people change oh oh
it's that simple
you fall in love with me and want a
romantic relationship nothing
changes for you with the exception of
feeling hunky dory all the time but what
about me holden
it's not that simple i just can't get
into a relationship with you without
throwing my whole [ __ ] world into
upheaval
listen that's every relationship there's
always gonna be a period of adjustment
a period of adjustment there's no
period of adjustment hold and i am
[ __ ] gay
that's who i am and you assume that i
can just turn all that around
because you've got a [ __ ] crush
[Music]
if this is a crush i don't think i can
take it if the real thing ever happened
go home holden
[Music]
hello
hey kids did you like that all these
movies are available on itunes or
netflix in some places
amazon and other places you can find
them they're available
patronize them if you will uh also if
you like this kind of stuff
come on over to that kevin smith club go
to thatkevinsmithclub.com
join up man i do wake and bake three
times a week where i wake up just smoke
weed with you all and stuff come to that
kevin smith club for more
video antics with kevin smith